s'il est un lieu qui sait de qui il
tient son nom c'est bien le lycée
polyvalent bois joly potier du tampon
ici on l'appelle bjp et son histoire se
décline sur tous les tons à travers des
tableaux réalisés par les élèves en 2002
mais aujourd'hui que reste-t-il de ce
travail
il s'appelait henri laurent parce que il
il a exploité des jolibois il a eu son
surnom de bois joli un fermier des aux
grands exploitants agricoles de la
plaine des cafres c'est nenê qui a
favorisé la culture je crois que nous
nous formons des géraniums et la
distillerie de géraniums plus important
de la nation
c'est à henri laurent dubois joly potier
que la plaine des cafres doit le
développement de son agriculture et de
son élevage
des 22 ans le jeune saint-pierrois croit
en l'avenir des eaux
les potiers sont implantées dans le sud
depuis déjà un siècle c'est donc à la
plaine des cafres qu'ils s'installent
ils se marient en 1852 avec louise
olympe armanet alors âgée de 14 ans puis
acquis en dix ans à peine plus de 350
hectares de terre
il développe l'élevage 600 moutons une
centaine de bleu des ports et bien sûr
des équipements en pierre à la chaux est
recouverte de bardeaux
il ouvre plus de 10 km de chemins ils
défrichent et cultive pommes de terre
avoine seigle orge prairies
artificielles
son exploitation fait l'admiration de
tous et sera d'ailleurs récompensé lors
de concours agricole
notre agriculteur est aussi le promoteur
du géranium c'est dans sa cuisine qu'il
tente les premières cuites sur un
alambic de fortune
sur une quarantaine d'hectares il plante
peu à peu le géranium va se répandre sur
les terres situées à plus de 600 mètres
d'altitude
à la fin du 19ème bois joly potier a
fait des émules
en 1880 il devient conseiller municipal
de saint pierre
bois joly potier meurt d'une fluxion de
poitrine à l'âge de 61 ans